foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
what's going on guys you should be able
to hear me
King is still
in the process of getting home he should
be home any second but I figured I'd pop
in here and see what's going on
let me do a sound test real quick
okay
is it not can you guys not hear me
can you guys hear me
what's up cam what's up uh Tyler what's
up uh Gavin Boone
Apex
we're still waiting for King King will
be here momentarily
him and Cog had to do something for
ioped so they had to go into
the great city of New York and get stuck
there
foreign
what's going on 108
look man I want you all
to take the leak of this
and go to Twitter
and tell them we're live
thank you
your busy ass City more like it
but you know when you have like a
million people
living
in a city it's gonna get it's gonna get
crowded man crowded really fast
I respect it
see I don't live in a traffic area like
that 108
just not for me
so I'm low-key starting to find out how
I want the show to go
uh we are still working out the Kinks
so
bear with me
bear with me guys bear with me
all right King is logging in currently
as we speak
so we good
sort of
high on life um I was thinking about
straining it
but
that means I'd have to stream it like
Thursday
and I'm already doing
a podcast today
tomorrow I did one Sunday
I don't know if I want and I'm doing a
stream Saturday
and I'm going out with my girl
third Friday
the reviews are BS I was seeing I was
seeing I was watching people play it oh
here's King
oh you're fine you're fine
all right go ahead and or not yet I know
they won't hear you yet
all right they should be able to hear
you now
what's going on people my bad
yeah I told I told him you was in the in
the city of uh of New York where uh no
one where no one cares about anything
for real I was in the belly of the Beast
ah look at
yeah they can hear you
what's going on people
I figured I'd talk to them and keep them
busy while it was waiting I do apologize
I was talking to 108 dragons while I was
driving getting home
we have very important stuff to do today
shout out to cognito
uh
so I hope I'm getting it done
this is uh what this is how things are
gonna go
I still want to fix these boxes make
them a little bit bigger uh you know
we'll get there eventually
uh like I said work with these guys work
with this uh
the good thing
is that
we got a good show for you guys so what
are we talking about King because you
kind of you kind of like the hosting of
this stuff because I don't know really a
whole lot of uh the DC stuff so we do we
are going to talk about troll
I did I literally just finished it like
40 minutes ago
I don't King told me he couldn't get to
attack on Titan this week so that gets
me off the hook with his anime until
next week well no no I still got to
watch it yeah so wait you didn't watch
it yet I'll watch like an episode I was
half asleep so we can talk about your
first impression I don't remember a
whole lot of it okay so we're gonna
we're gonna let him off the hook today
we're gonna let him go back you know to
to Baki but I I I will get to it next uh
this week yeah well I do apologize guys
next week we're going to be talking
about um
what uh
Avatar so oh yeah um yeah we gotta go
see Avatar this week
yeah okay so that should actually make
those look a lot better now
all right so
first thing we're going to talk about
because I actually set up my stream deck
this week now it's not it's not entirely
fixed yet
I still need stream deck icons which I
don't know if graphic God gave us or not
but I do have like if you look at the
screen now I had to put a black eye a
black screen behind the the IOP screen
to make it look like that
uh so so now we don't have to worry
about like us being transparent through
stuff good that black screen is actually
helping us stick like helping me keep
track of the show because what it does
is it pretty much says I don't want
nothing from the show
I don't want no other image leaking in
this black screen because look if I get
rid of this black screen yeah
so this is how that's how the show gonna
go guys uh first off we're gonna talk
about the troll
then we'll talk about the DC stuff
that's going on because there's a
there's a lot going on with DC sir
and then I have got together
a list of it's like that that website
this is how it's gonna look I actually
named it in my thing called the show and
tell
and uh because that that's what I'm
gonna call it is the show and tell so
pretty much what we're gonna do is me
King
we are going to rank which let me go
ahead and fix this real quick we're
going with Kevin Samuels Kevin says
we're going to rake all of the
see uh all of them
the
phase four uh movies and TV shows so
this is how that's going to look I'm
sure you'll see here in a second king uh
yes s a b c d uh and pretty much how
we're just gonna do it is uh I can see
the actual screen and King will be able
to see it but you guys won't be able to
see the actual movies that we rank until
we pick them up uh see I can show you
like right here you'll see one of them
but that's the only one I'm going to
show you uh so pretty much me and him
are going to go over that we're going to
give our good good opinions on that now
I I am kind of skeptical now because I
know when I share my screen it's going
to screw up this whole overlay so we'll
see how it goes but anyway let's let's
get straight into the show man let's get
straight in the show the first thing
we're going to talk about is Troll and
look at this King I actually have the
troll icon now just pop up I just push a
button no no
not doing crazy so which is funny I'm
looking at the troll icon that I got
from Google right right
that scene is not in the movie
it's not in the movie well I didn't see
it yet because remember I'm on a tape
delay
so it's going to pop up right now
yeah hell no that scene
don't you love when they be getting one
up on you man yo because you know what
I'm gonna keep it real when I saw the
Netflix joint that's that's the that's
the um what they use to advertise it and
it's a lot it's a complete lie yeah they
acted like it it's that's gonna happen
you know what's funny well first off
this
this movie is like kind of like a
monster type of movie when I first saw
it I thought it was going to be like a
Godzilla moment where they they
befriended thank God it didn't go that
way because I'm tired of those movies
it's definitely uh you know it's a solid
found you know how I know it's gonna be
a decent movie when it's on the top 10
of top movies being watched on Netflix
that's the only reason why I looked at
and and besides the fact that I'm a
troll so I said uh
I want to watch a movie about myself
and I wasn't disappointed I really liked
the bond between the father and the
daughter
big and little you know
um
I notice a lot of movies uh take that uh
stance you know the big person and and
the little you know instead of saying
adult and child you know
[Music]
and he really he really loved his
daughter and she really thought her
father was off the deep end talking
about this law and and all this troll
nonsense
um I I just I I found it very nice
because he was right
he was right yeah what's funny is they
kind of didn't they kind of made you
think there's more going on there than
meets the eye like they would be more
significant of okay well let's not go
into the detail but uh so pretty much
it's just a movie about uh you know a
mother and father like kind of being The
Adventurous type but it doesn't really
go into that doesn't really like dig
into their relationship much of anything
uh if you're expecting like in-depth
storytelling this is not the movie for
you this is pretty much just a uh like
boom boom shot shot kind of movie like
you know got a creature and you know
what's funny this thing never runs
no it literally walks the entire time
and you know you can't find it they
never can find and it's shooting you
know it's fine they're shooting like
stuff at it the whole time obviously
it's like a kind of like a Godzilla type
of movie and I've seen her the whole
time thinking
is this all you guys got
so you know uh you know
I think it's I think it's okay you know
um what would you give it in stars like
I think it's an okay movie yeah I think
I think three stars fine too and three I
mean three popcorn
it you know why I gave it three popcorn
why it had the moment where all right so
remember in Godzilla 2000
um a mass little Broderick was uh in the
car and he was driving with the babies
in the back or something like that and
he was getting Godzilla to chase after
the car so they have a moment in this
movie but it goes wrong and then what's
funny it goes wrong let me put the
spoiler up real quick we're gonna spoil
something real quick not much but I I do
need to put that spoiler up yeah after
credit scene is dope as hell yeah
oh there's an after credit see yo you
got to stop leaving these movies B
that I I didn't know there's an after
credit dude you did that with
um with bullet train too
did you go back to see the after credit
if I say yes will you not make fun of me
over it nah you lying exactly I said
yesterday yes this guy's crazy
yo please see it because it it really I
mean that movie it was just it just put
the bow on it but um this gotta after
credit scene too if that's correct it's
kind of crazy how like these movies are
getting after credit scenes at this
point like everything they're like
Marvel things gotta have after credit do
you think this movie gets a sequel
yeah it kind of kind of puts itself in
the top 10 of Netflix yeah it kind of
felt that way it's gonna get a sequel uh
but
I think I think you I think people would
enjoy it do I think it's like
an amazing thing no but I do think it's
worth watching at least once uh you know
I felt like
there's a lot of movies that you can
watch Once and not feel like you've been
robbed it's different than playing a
video game once you get about three or
four hours in a video game and then you
start feeling robbed there ain't no
worse feeling no going back kind of like
playing God of War Ragnarok
so you know I I personally feel like you
guys will enjoy it I do recommend it uh
you know I feel like three stars it's
worth the watching now once we started
getting like the one to two stars that's
when you're like nah I don't watch that
yeah sure you know you you dodge at it
as much as you can so
this is this is worth your time like I
mean you get one of those nights and
you're like yo what do you want to watch
and this is worth your time
so okay
you know
I think
we need to go straight to the to the
business to the business DC so explain
to me exactly what's going on because my
friend Tyler yo what's funny is he kind
of took a jab at me because of when he
super chatted last week and I said he
was my friend in high school he's like
and I'm gonna act like you didn't say my
friend in high school acted like we
ain't friends now we ain't friends now
and I was like yeah they like that man
it ain't like so I formally take that
back okay I I communicate with this man
almost weekly but uh so he's told me a
little bit but what what is going on
well it looks like so DC is on the house
is on fire like all right so James Gunn
the the director of all the Guardians of
the Galaxy movies right and the guard I
think he did the guardian of the galaxy
Christmas
he's coming over well he's now in charge
of uh WB uh DC Universe right he's in
charge of that
and he's wiping the Slate clean
and talking about this is going to be
you know like his stamp and he didn't
like the Wonder Woman script
so he pushed that to the side
uh the the man is still two no good and
the numbers came back from Black Adam
which was piss poor
so he wants to reboot the whole universe
now the only two movies so far that is
safe or the only two franchises of
movies that will get done that are safe
is the Joker franchise with Joaquin
Phoenix
and Lady Gaga is going to be in a sequel
is the next one right
um but real quick isn't technically
The Joker franchise isolated like it's
not part of any of the unit that's why
they can easily do it right and the
Robert Patterson Batman
that's another one because they're
picking him to be the next Batman right
I don't the way it is it's like an else
worlds type of thing DC has this thing
called elseworlds
um
Marvel has uh what if they have Earth
else worlds and this is like you know
like a what-if imaginary world so the
Robert Patterson Batman dwells in that
world he's not in the mainline DC
Universe so what James Gunn wants to do
is reboot the mainline DC Universe
so we don't know if it ends
with uh the The Flash movie the
flashpoint movie or they just wiped that
when he was pointing I thought you was
pointing to me no no okay I have uh
someone's on my bed and they're like can
they see me I'm like no like this
they're used to like open area addict on
IOP and stuff like this is this is
pretty much just my face like that's
right FaceTime yeah so here's how I feel
about it
I would I kind of got like the hint I I
saw some rumors pop up that he didn't
officially cancel Wonder Woman the
characters of Wonder Woman Like it was
like Yeah The Leader the lead writer
they denied her script or something like
that or him or her script and and what I
guess she quit so that followed the
Wonder Woman actress quitting as well
and then once you lost them at that
point he was probably gonna cancel it
but I guess he's like yo this is this is
probably gonna be the one that would
have hurt like
publicly would have hit got him the most
backlash and he's like yo she just she
just let me off the look the lease the
hook I don't have to do nothing now like
I'm good
people are so upset that uh that Henry
Cavill because remember Henry Cavill or
out you know let's
let's have a moment of silence
for Henry Cavill leaving Witcher
to get his own show cancel
like you know that's crazy man I'm so
happy now I can go watch The Witcher
[Music]
no no maybe maybe if I watch The Witcher
I can see him more in The Witcher role I
don't see him as soon as I already gave
you my reasons why but um yeah maybe I
can watch The Witcher now and see what
he did he was a good Witcher so I mean I
heard I hear that but I hear that mostly
from Henry Cavill fans
I'm not really a Henry Cavill fan well I
think I remember when he was first
announced as The Witcher as Gary
there was a lot of hate remember that
there was a lot of hate but after I
watched that first season I didn't
really like the second I dropped the
second like three or four episodes in
but that first season it was good it was
really good like so let me ask you a
question
who would you want to play with the cast
as Superman
if you if you had a choice oh you or
Wonder Woman do you have any actors or
actresses that you feel that uh could
fit in these roles because I know for a
fact they they're getting rid of Ezra
Miller I know for a fact that he needs
to get out of there because that dude is
a real life villain so
um
I'm horrible at casting to be honest
with you because uh I I know people buy
the roles they play and not their names
if that makes sense right
um I don't really know too many people
that could play Superman at this point I
think it would have to be a younger
actor I don't really keep up with them
too too much
I think they should probably go the
Marvel Way by taking a bike huh no brand
like a a a a no-name individual opposed
to a name individual well it's not even
just like a no-name just an up and
coming that they take like like a chance
on you know what I'm saying because I
feel like somebody new uh this guy who
plays Spider-Man and stuff for his stuff
on
um like a Broadway and now look at him
like one of the best fighters that's
what I'm talking about yeah I'm talking
about like a no-name uh actor
I actually really liked homegirl is is
Wonder Woman though like I felt like she
played a good Wonder Woman yeah me too I
was mad she died on that sword yeah she
should have you know what's funny in a
couple years she's probably gonna regret
that choice in her career I hope at some
point in time they can walk that back
because I do like her as Wonder Woman
because now it's going to be hard for me
to see a Wonder Woman without her being
in the water world because she did such
a good job doing it I think two was a
visible I hated that movie I think one
was good I loved one Wonder Woman one
you know I just I hate that I know
you're not a fan of Henry but man I hate
that he gave up that Witcher contract
and that what's your show it seemed like
it was more Mutual like he was going to
give it up regardless you know what I'm
saying but it's one thing that you're
gonna give it up is another thing that
you're low-key tricked to giving it like
and then imagine like he he went through
all that stuff to to do the Black Adam
thing they get this thing that they're
doing and they're like oh we're canning
all that like and you know it'd be
different if he got into like like a
like one movie or two movies this man
did a cameo he quit a star row on
Netflix for a cameo
in the rock made sure that he got that
cami
is remember if you saw the end of Shazam
WB was iffy on Henry Cavill so you saw
the suit there but you didn't see the
man's face and The Rock said he didn't
want that he wanted his face so he
wanted it to be known that Henry Cavill
was playing Superman the whole thing he
was gonna play Superman for half to have
that happen it's kind of crazy
um I see somebody put in there no name
like Robert Downey Jr remember at the
time that was that's different though
was no but he was yeah he was this great
talent she was talent but he he he was
pretty much like he wasn't even really
acting at the time like he was
blacklisted for most places you know I I
saw a documentary where he was so bad
off that the only way that they would
officially because keep in mind that's
how bad comic books was at the time
where
someone like Robbie Downey Jr even
though that he was he was a bigger actor
still was like
I don't know and he ended up doing it
because no one else was given an
opportunity they they they hired private
investigators I saw a documentary to
watch him
for I think it was Iron Man one
and Iron Man 2. those two films after
Iron Man 2 I think uh is when they
stopped but it's like they literally
followed this man around to make sure he
wasn't doing nothing huh and the drug
testing yeah drug testing it but
remember yeah he had a huge problem I
mean from from the from the last movie
if anything Marvel's saved his life yeah
they did and I think but they gave him
so much control
but he was good at it though they had to
kill him they had to kill him he was
good at it and I think Doctor Strange
just kind of took his place since then
that's why I think like
that's what DC's messing up they refuse
to commit to anything the moment
something doesn't make a Marvel type of
money or Marvel type of branding or
Marvel type of profit they're like pull
the plug they ejecto like
[Applause]
you know what I think though I think
James Gunn
is going to bring to the universe a
stability
we have a super chat uh from Tyler
Crosby to our Super Chat we need
Nightwing in the movies
uh is Nightwing is
Batman land right or right see that's
brought up and uh grown right if you if
you see Teen Titans that's to do have
you seen Teen Titans yeah yes okay so
you know who Nightwing is that's the guy
that was robbing and then he switches
over to Nightwing okay I've seen the
cartoon Teen Titans oh okay well he's
Nightwing after a period of time okay
because that's what Tyler told me back
in the day I just can't remember
because I know there's like 15 different
Batmans 15 different different robins
like I I can't keep up with them all
well there's there's only four different
robins
um there's one then one of them get
killed yeah by the Joker yeah Jason Todd
it's kind of crazy with a crowbar they
just let him kill that that's funny man
that's funny no if if you watch the TV
show
um the Teen Titans before HBO Max goes
dead uh you get a better sense of why
uh Jason Todd got killed they did a
great depiction of who Jason Todd is
from the comic books over to I actually
I really like the cartoon Teen Titans
like I really the cartoon is pretty good
but the the TV show is equally as well
as is good it's not HBO Max yes I might
watch a couple episodes
once you watch it you're gonna get
hooked because they have uh these two
characters called Hawk and Dove and
back in the days I mean I got a ton of
those comic books but um I purchased
Hulk and Dove books for a while and
those are Niche characters and I didn't
think or expect them to do those
characters in in HBO uh series and they
did them and they really did them to
Perfection you know the guy who plays
Hulk is really good the girl who plays
Dove is really good you will like each
one and hate each one for individual
things but um I've been they did a real
good job with Teen Titans I've been
meaning to go back and watch like the
seasons of Flash and like the seasons of
um because I kept up with flash to a
point I ain't gonna lie though man Tyler
when you moved away I dropped Arrow
entirely because I like flash but see
here's the thing like I like flash when
he's up against a Speedster when he's
not up against the Speedster I'm like
I'll see you next season
so then you will like the last like the
last four seasons the last four seasons
of The Flash
he was up against the reverse flash and
then the speed death and then he had uh
people uh from other dimensions coming
over I like
Zoom that was my favorite Professor Zoom
the the one where uh he he took him he
like he beat his he beat him up around
the whole city and took him to the
police station and he just dropped him
he's like and then he's like this is
what you made me do and he's like what
he's like please don't do it he kills
everybody in the police station
see that's what I like like I don't mind
Arrow I felt like arrow is a good show
but I just I felt like it started losing
my interest around like what he would
Raul's al Ghul when he beat raoz al Ghul
the season after that on the last season
I watched it was with my my friend Tyler
he was like on a like a boat with his
son in the in the island exploded and
that's the last thing I saw of Arrow
like well he he ended that series they
ended that series on a high especially
um what is it uh what is that I think
it's Star Girl
I think that's what it's called but you
have um they have a bunch of different
lines that branched off like heroes of
Tomorrow I like that stuff because they
have Brandon Roth uh the guy that played
Superman and Superman Returns and um in
in one of those Earth's elseworld uh
shows he came back and replies his role
as Superman I always thought he was the
best Superman for me
so um I thought
WB
did a great job at the TV shows yeah
they're very good TV shows I would
actually
we're about to get into the Marvel TV
shows because phase four is when they
started the TV shows but yeah
I'm gonna make a bold statement
and say DC shows destroy Marvel shows
like I don't even think it's on the same
round like the first but my thing is
like they can't keep a narrative over a
long basis to me like the first couple
seasons of era was awesome amazing but
then pretty much after you learned about
what happened on the island because they
get you with that hook with the island
but after all that happened and they
okay Raj al Ghul and then after that
happened it was like and then I just
started feeling like I was losing
interest so like I feel like that flash
was good
um you know days until uh what is it
tomorrow here's tomorrow I like that
show I mean I don't think it was as good
as the other ones but I do feel like
their shows are better but they're
moving the character developments are
better but I feel like they're movies or
God awful I see and that's where Marvel
and DC has the flip but I think the
Disney Plus shows or like you have kids
um real quick let me see this real quick
I feel like the Disney Plus shows
uh are better
than DC's movies like if you want to
compare the two like like I do feel like
if you want to compare it to like going
to the vice versa like the movies
when you flip them around
I do feel like the DC shows are better
than the Marvel uh the the the Marvel TV
shows are better than the DC movies and
it shouldn't be that way like those TV
shows are better than the universe of
the movies and it's crazy that if you
really think about a king it's
impressive that they have they had put
together
TV and movies in a one universe that
that's actually insane if you really sit
and think about it but they didn't see
the thing with that is
they had a mission
and they stuck to the script no matter
how bumpy some of the roads got because
a lot of stuff wasn't well received like
you know uh what is this uh Captain
Marvel with uh Camilla Khan you know
that wasn't so well hold on let me get
Spartan gold 17 with the two pound Super
Chat uh public poll and 88 chose to kill
Jason in the comic books this is true
right so remember
comic books was doing different things
at the period of time and like the
Marvel versus DC that was all fan voted
and to kill Jason Todd or to let him
live
he irritated the fan base so much
we wanted him dead
I voted
to kill him and I really didn't think it
was gonna happen and when they did it I
was like oh my god when I got the comic
book
um yeah so Deathstroke right it's bloody
that stroke was an arrow right yeah yeah
I like that dude the want the red mask
yeah the one that kind of like teamed up
with them throughout the show the half
yeah I like that I liked him I did like
him he was a good whoa all right so the
the WB TV shows
I had a better cohesiveness than uh some
of the the Marvel TV shows but I gotta
say the Disney plus stuff
um being that it shares the world with
the Marvel world of of the movies it
kind of has a leg up
because they're smaller condensed in
size the Disney the the WB stuff they
series after series after season after
season after season whereas falcon and a
winter soldier they only had like what
is it like eight to ten episodes uh Max
and you know you had that story told
there so
I think the production value in in the
Disney plus stuff is higher than a
production value in the WB stuff but the
Teen Titans production value is pretty
high too yeah I feel like the reason for
that is Disney's willing to invest more
because they know on the movie side and
plus with Disney's subscription Services
they'll get that money back eventually
yeah well you also they're more
successful so when you're more
successful you can take more risks like
with your TV show to to fill up the
subscription base here's my question to
you and we're going to use the uh the
the popcorn for this
give me a one to five rating on this
individual coming from Marvel fixing the
DC
oh Jason uh James Gunn
I think I think four I swear I think he
can do it
I think you can do it
I'm gonna give it a three all right let
me tell you what oh let me let me say my
first I personally feel like he did
Guardians one was my one of my favorite
show movies here we go but it's
different than making those movies than
establishing a franchise of movies
stories are going together I gotta see
how they handle
they already have all these TV shows
that are successful are they not I don't
want them double casting I don't want
the TV person and then the movie person
like if the team I want a single
universe that's not like oh you know
what what about the flash Oh you mean
the TV flash or the movie Flash like
okay so you do know that they canceled
all the TV stuff
all that stuff is dead I didn't know
that yeah so all that stuff is dead all
right
um and that's when they did the merger
with uh Comcast and all that other stuff
and ATT and all that other stuff all
right so that's dead
now what you have is this this universe
that James Gunn is is going to uh fix
the reason why I say he can do it
is because in the comic books Guardians
of the Galaxy isn't a top selling book
right and he gave us our entryway into
the Marvel Galaxy of of of of the
extended galaxy of the Marvel Universe
usually you have the Fantastic Four
usually you have uh others
um uh what is it that in humans in
humans flop miserably right to take us
into space because they're they're
stationed on the moon they flop
miserably James Gunn came and gave us
Guardians of the Galaxy Peter Quill
where we don't care about these
characters but he made them so funny so
charismatic that we actually cared about
it and then from there was the jumping
point of the Marvel extended galaxy
universe we got the eternals and stuff
like that and that was facilitated
basically through the Guardians of the
Galaxy and they used those same
characters to push Thor love and thunder
and to help and and um Infinity Gauntlet
and infinity War so I think James Gunn
has the chops and the ability to make
you care about characters that you
wouldn't never really cared about so I
think his first movie that he should
start with is really green lantern
that's my opinion of it actually Tyler
told me today that he actually brought
up Green Lantern in specifically
apparently like and what you know I know
I'm gonna get really bad smoke for this
I sent you the link to what we're gonna
do after this I want you to do it with
this because the moment I share my
screen with you it's going to take our
cameras off and I think you would prefer
our cameras to be there while we're
doing it
um
I actually liked Ryan reynolds's Green
Lantern like I know I'm like
the the weirdo
yeah on that but I actually felt like
his Green Lantern was funny like you
know keep in mind I'm a person from the
outside looking in I don't know anything
about the Green Lanterns if anything it
got me enough curiosity to go and
actually look up some of the lore of the
Green Lantern like I know about like uh
they have multiple Rings like the red
ring the orange Rings uh
what now I'm looking at what you got in
front of me yeah you don't have to do it
I you just I want you to visually see
what I'm doing okay so yeah so I just
have to make it a little bit bigger here
because those thumbnails are so tiny but
I can see them
wow are you serious yeah we're gonna
rank all those
yeah we're in trouble
I actually I do you think that they're
going to use because it to me what they
messed up on was
was rushing that Justice League out
I felt like that it that you you went
into a Justice League with only
realistically two people had a movie at
that time the Aquaman and uh and
Superman
so to me
there because at that time I don't think
there was a Wonder Woman yet was there
but I think when the Justice League yeah
there was a Wonder Woman so Wonder Woman
one came out before then but remember
they didn't know if she was with them or
not so I don't I don't I don't remember
be honest with you they could have did
that disjointed Tyler put in the chat
was Wonder Woman before the Justice
League or after I'm wanting to say it
was after because Superman versus Batman
versus Superman's when they originally
introduced her
so yeah you might be right she was
introduced but she didn't get her own
movie that's what it was I think she was
introduced but she didn't have her own
movie
I and I felt like
if they would have gave a couple of
these people like the main people that
was in there cyborg flash if they wore
if they were to get
them their movies and then they go into
that Justice League they don't have to
explain people's past they could spend
more time on The Narrative of the movie
I felt like
the whole point of Superman is dead kind
of like was like uh like running around
on its axle the entire movie he didn't
really know what was going on and then
it's like so you mean you all you really
showed me was you can't do nothing
without Superman
what what what I take okay so um it was
March of uh was it March of 2016 Batman
versus Superman came out right and
um in Batman versus Superman
one woman it shows up Wonder Woman
movies come out the year later right uh
so she was introduced in yeah Batman
versus because she because I remember a
lot of people got upset because her
blight cut doomsdays like arm off or
something yeah and apparently like
nothing we should be able to do that
like that was complete cap I didn't know
I thought it was like when I was
watching I thought it was lit
a lot of stuff that they did was really
off brand right
um but again
in the sake of telling a story they
should have let Zack Snyder control the
universe
Warner Brothers did not want to let Zack
Snyder have control right and I think if
they gave Zack Snyder because I think
Zack Snyder's cut of um the Justice
League was a better cut than Josh's it
was you know because he's the one that
had that moment with the flash at the
end wasn't he yeah yeah that that moment
was better than the entire original cut
like just because like it's just little
things like that even though you know
homeboy kind of crazy you know
just just like they told him never to go
that fast and then he was like after he
saw the world ending he's like I gotta
go as fast as I ever went it shows him
rewinding time yeah but he's he's able
to do that he's that he's that speedster
um I just want somebody
that's gonna love the characters I
thought
Zack Snyder's view on Heroes is a little
bit twisted
it's dark
right and I think James Gunn's views on
Heroes
is a better Outlook
so I I think he he he doesn't view
Heroes as tragic individuals that are
plagued by their powers right James Gunn
Zack Snyder views Heroes as tragic
individuals that are plagued by their
powers right so powers that they want to
give up powers that are cursed to them I
I actually feel like
the dark thing let me let me get Tyler's
Super Chat real quick sorry we got Tyler
Crosby Super Chat 1.99 well two dollars
I'm gonna give you two dollars Tyler
um King how do you feel about Tyler Kish
in DC I have no clue who that is who is
Tyler Kish
just put it in a regular chat
because like if you if you tell me um
like who he is in the Regular Show I'm
very pissed poor with names put in a
regular chat I read it from the regular
chat you don't have to Super Chat that
oh I'll read it to you but sorry attic
Guys Tyler Kish looks like
he's the dude that played in Lone
Survivor Friday Night Lights battleship
um
I don't I don't know where he's
referring to him like in the in DC
[Music]
maybe it's a role that he wants me to
see him play he does pop up like when I
put DC in what what what what did what's
going on Tyler yeah just put it in there
what's going on while we continue I just
I feel like Snyder is like dark thing
works well it's just I feel like he can
never Friday Night Lights Battleship
game but in Wolverine
oh okay so you're talking about the dude
who played John Carter
who's John Carter yeah the guy who he
all right so he played Gambit uh he
played uh John Carter the movie I love
that movie John Carter oh man they were
supposed to do so much stuff with that
movie
um
what what do you want him to be you want
him to be Superman do you do you uh I
don't know like the question to be
honest with you but is he a viable
candidate hell yeah he played John
Carter John Carter is crazy that's for
for a lot of people that don't know that
movie y'all really need to go back and
check that he kind of looks like he
could play Superman
quite possibly I mean we we already have
a Mexican Superman and Lois Lane versus
uh I mean Lowe's John Carter yeah he
said John Carter
yeah
hold on maybe a Green Lantern he could
play a green lantern with a five pound
Super Chat yeah definitely Green Lantern
uh gun was meant to to helm phase four
before the controversy and asked him
yeah he was it was meant to start
Guardian four just got to keep DC kind
of serious side yes you are right and
then they fought for uh for James Gunn
to come back all I I those actors banded
together because they was not going to
do guardians 3 without him and because
remember it was about a tweet that he
did so long ago and I forgot the context
of the tweet and I really don't care
about the context of the Tweet because
sometimes you talk in the vacuum and you
think you're not being heard but you're
being recorded so um yeah man please
um he came back to do guardians 3 and
hopefully it's probably one of his best
before he goes he was supposed to do uh
phase four and I don't think we'd have
got the walk phase four that we got uh
to be honest with you you I think there
was a lot of agendas going on Facebook
yeah we're about to get to Facebook
I think it would have been something a
lot more grounded especially how James
Gunn tells his story he tells the story
with a lot of heart so I think it would
have been a lot more grounded and heart
yeah so he said uh maybe Green Lantern
or John Carter who is John Carter
John Carter is the man so he goes to
Mars
I try to watch that um it's not DC it's
the Watchman that that TV show watching
I didn't know how to drop that like like
a bag of bricks man like it it started
out really good but I just started
losing me man you talk about the HBO
series yeah the HBO series see I was so
turned off okay so the comic book itself
is very dark see that's what I'm talking
about Zack Snyder's thought process when
it comes to Heroes his thought process
is very tragic you know what zaxonida
said
what he would have done if instead of
Christopher Nolan's Batman's he would
have had Batman raped in jail oh
yes
oh yeah I can't say that uh he would
have had Batman uh
I mean you already said it kid it's not
like you take it back sometimes I when
I'm when I'm talking with you I forget
that I'm on camera
um he would have had Batman violated in
jail
see I like the backstory stuff but to me
how is Batman gonna get violated in jail
Batman but he didn't know nothing about
about what you would call it yet
okay so this is when you know Batman's
learning his his craft but he goes to
jail remember Christopher Nolan sends
Batman to jail and uh he learns and
that's when he meets Raz al Ghul and he
learns the way of the Unseen right but
he would have had Batman violated in
jail and I don't know how that pushes
The Narrative of Batman you know except
for shock value so again
Zack Snyder's view to me on Heroes is
very dark so if you're going to go with
James Gunn
James Gunn is going to give you a lot of
heart in his characters so a lot of uh
hope in his characters what if James
gone and Snyder came together and no
something you don't think Warner
Brothers doesn't want Snyder anywhere
close to anything I don't understand
like why
I get it
yeah I get it they're under a lot of
pressure and stuff but it's just like I
just get annoyed that
we let stuff people and you know we
ain't gonna go too into that too much
it's just like we hit up the consumers
end up suffering so now if like
whatever they do next with Guardian
suffers is because you know homeboy you
don't be crazy if they made that
decision off of a tweet or or being
recorded or whatever and he ended up
taking DC to the promised land I think
he will
I think I think he I think he's going to
make he's going to take DC to the
promised land and he's got something to
prove too there ain't nothing more
deadly than a man that got something to
prove and and I think he's gonna get it
done I think his last great movie uh in
the Marvel universe is going to be
Guardians of the Galaxy but what he
wants to do is he wants to beat Marvel
at their own game so and he has a
Pantheon of iconic characters to do so I
mean his quiver is full of arrows no pun
intended you got green arrow you have
Green Lantern you have Shazam you have a
Superman you have Wonder Woman you have
other characters that's you know besides
the Flash and they roll galleries of
villains you can do
um Solomon Grundy a real good Solomon
Grundy a real good Swamp Thing you can
really do a lot of good characters and
bring them to the screen so I think
James Gunn has a ton of characters that
he can work with but um
uh Don sicario King would you want to
see Jon Stewart Green Lantern or Hal
Jordan again
I just finished watching uh Disney a
Disney uh a DC cartoon with Jon Stewart
and I thought that cartoon was done
impeccably I always think DC cartoons
are great I always they they've they've
never missed for me to be honest with
you it was funny the only thing they've
missed is their movies yeah that's it
like why can't you take what you've done
in the movie or in in the cartoons and
translate that straight to you know what
it is I've been told D like
Warner Brothers loves to put their hands
in the cookie jar when it comes down
I bet you they see like the cartoons and
the TV shows as relevant but when they
see that movie they see that as like you
can make triple if they feel like they
can get it done the way it should be
done or just just do the cartoon and
translate it so let's let's let's let's
let's get to this phase I got to get to
this phase let's get to this phase four
you got my appetite wet for this all
right so
here is
the face uh the phases yeah so how we're
going to do this is if there's rules all
right so one of the rules is
if either one of us ain't watched one of
these which I think you've seen them all
I haven't seen every one of them you
then you pretty much Auto get that the
if we both have seen it we have to agree
on where it goes and we cannot go
further until we agree okay uh but I
will say one thing I will give us each a
veto
if you are tired of the other person you
get one veto okay so you could just
override mine so the first one we're
gonna do
is uh
let me zoom in on this
because it is kind of hard to see yeah
the thumbnails is crazy uh Hawkeye is
the first one
okay
Hulk out a TV show
I give it a b
I think B's fair I think be fair is
nothing like serious uh but I do think
that you know it did what it was
supposed to I don't think it like
outlived its its opinion but I do think
you know it did what it was supposed to
all right so uh what what what where
we're gonna put it looks like Moon night
I think that next one's moon tonight
let me get my phone so I can just zoom
in I got uh Moon Knight is right there
so uh
brother you get to pick where it goes
because I didn't see it good I'm gonna
give it an s-rated ass ranking I'm gonna
give it a oh I I ain't gonna lie I was
probably gonna veto that ass it's it's
an a it's an a because
um Isaac
does such a damn big knob
as every character that he plays
Oscar Isaac I need to watch that I've
been told by a lot of people that it's
good I need to just watch it give it a
chance and I don't even think it's all
like I had anything against it I just
think there was stuff going on at the
time and I didn't get a chance to like
sit there and watch it because that came
out like right after uh Hawkman Hawk I
didn't know
yeah yeah probably just like
just timing for the most part let's
let's pick another one here hold up let
me pick one
werewolf what is that oh oh you didn't
see you didn't see wolf by night no
I gotta give that a b
okay I I won't argue because I can't and
I'm not going to use my stuff on all
right let's put chat give me one what's
the next one we should do I'm gonna let
you guys pick one give me one give me
the next one and I'm just gonna throw
that out there anyone does a Super Chat
that gets picked over anything
um what's the next one we pick what's
the next one we pick give you guys a
couple seconds to pick
we don't got no s's no C's and no D's
I'm gonna tell you right now you pick
you pick you pick
you picked Thor it's gonna be the first
d
I'm just gonna be real if you guys you
pick Thor it's gonna be the first love
and thunder yeah it's gonna be the first
this is a d yes if there was uh off the
chart it would be that one one division
I think that one's One Division because
some of them are so small it's hard to
see which one they are yep
um One Division yeah it's that one
where are we put in one Division I think
I think one division's an a
H I give it a c i c okay okay King
explain to me why this this thing
deserves a c
all right it deserves a c because
um it was out of touch with a lot of the
Millennials a lot of the Gen X's
um
I I felt that
it only very early on only talked to my
generation
and then it progressively and I and I
guess that was the intent of the show
but for the first couple of episodes if
it didn't grab you
you fell off of it and I know a lot of
people that fell off of a Wanda Vision
so
some people
I think that was the intention the
intention to make people don't watch no
no I think the intent like I'm talking
about like you're referring to the the
time Jump the time Jump thing right I
think
all that was intentional to show that
her mind is so warped now you know what
I'm saying like I think it would be hard
to to demonstrate that without doing it
the way they did it all right so did you
get the I Dream of Genie stuff
no I did right so we're both sitting
there and I gotta look over to you and
explain what we're doing what if next
because what the Angry Birds super
chatted and said what if question
let me see uh the angry therapist said
what if so we're doing what if now oh
yeah we definitely gonna do whatever
next
um
I'll I'll make a compromise with you and
I go B with one division
I still want to give it an A but you
know what I I'm gonna compromise with me
I'm a cow I'm a compromise with you
because I I want that same linger
towards me later on in this thing so
what we're going to be now which one's
what if because
I think it's it's the cartoon when I
know that but what if it's right after
um
so it's it's yeah all right so what if
after what if I think one of I think one
if it's a b
I know what if it's definitely an a an a
an a did you finish all of it yes
so you mean to tell me
what if the one that gave you the
strongest sorcerer Supreme that they
didn't do nothing with the doctor
strange may I ask well they didn't do
that that's like Doctor Strange movie
that's their business that's like
teasing me for six months and not giving
me the business when it happened you
were talking about Doctor Stranger movie
we're talking about what if the show but
I'm talking this is face for my brother
this is the whole sequence
we're talking about what if what if was
come on man what cartoon you know what's
worse talking about what I've given this
thing
a b
I know hey I I gotta go with a on what
if man I mean
I I it's it's I think it it earned part
it earned a what if two season two the
strength of what if itself I mean come
on man oh man Captain Carter
you're muted yeah no I'm not muted I'm
baffled
I'm baffled by this nonsense that you're
throwing out right now listen man I'm
telling you I think I think you capping
real hard for this what if man but think
about it Captain Carter actually became
a character because of what it is
and got rocks in Doctor Strange I'm not
stop talking about Dr Strange we're
talking about what if right now don't
worry about that you know it would have
been a better thing what if what if she
never got Captain Doctor Strange that's
the one if I want to hear about you're
using what if
all right you know what
let's give it a b
no
now you're gonna you want to use your
your compromise on on what if all right
now all right well I'll use it I'll give
it a a I'll give it a because I'm not
gonna have you ruin my fun because you
know listen you know the real reason why
I'm so high on what if hmm I told people
a long time ago Ultron was a way more
deadlier villain than than
um Thanos and anybody else and Ultron is
the main protagonist antagonist inside
what if yeah he got robbed too yeah yeah
he his character could have it uh I gave
it an a it's a no I think someone said c
addict
you know what guys gosh
it's not saying anything
all right so well
let's go and pick pick another one here
um
Black Widow
oh that's the D
I think it's a c
yeah
yo it's literally the weakest out of
everything I think I think Thor is
arguably weaker than this you think
is weaker than this one at least I was
enjoyed with this movie I rolled my eyes
all a Thor all right let me tell you I
quiet as cap
I have a super crush on the New Black
Widow his hot sister she she she's she's
she's a goat like she is especially in
um and uh and Hawkeye when they're going
down the elevator she's like are we
really gonna do this again
I I have a super crush on her
but you listen I'm willing to go see
with it I'm willing to go see with it
okay okay
all right Spider-Man
oh no that's that's an S that's s s it's
not even an argument not even a little
bit of conversation it's like like
that's one of those things if you chose
to be an A on veto it love you for sure
that's awesome
um let's go She-Hulk
huh controversy I watched all the
episodes with three so I have a good
idea of what the episodes are
controversy
um I think
it was good enough to get a B I mean I I
don't okay thank you thank you I don't
think so here's the thing I think people
are scheduling
bad
practices of walk okay things like I'm
not saying that they didn't do stuff
that was woke but I think people felt
like
they're supposed to make that video
like it's towards a male audience and it
wasn't and it's like look like
we can't really speak like I know a lot
of people got mad when she's like you
have to control your anger and she's
like having control of my anger and this
maybe she couldn't have been more vocal
about like being in a man's world maybe
that's the reason people got more upset
than anything but I can understand why
people felt the way they did but I felt
like it was entertaining at the end of
the day I I loved it so I can't be angry
with it let me get the angry therapist
MD with the five dollar uh Super Chat
thank you very much I appreciate
everything Black Widow is a d just for
what they did to Taskmaster you are not
telling a lie sir you are okay okay
cause you super chatted I I will veto
myself well I'm not using my veto but
I'll put it to a d thank you because
what they did to the iconic character he
is the he trains mercenaries and then oh
they they butchered their character
we got a two dollar super jump from
Spartan go 17. She-Hulk was an F it was
it was badly written throughout you
heard right so what we could take it and
put it to a seat
are we gonna really let the chat bully
us yeah
Super Chat so let's let's put it to a
seat he can't win I'm not gonna let you
give it a f I'm not gonna let you give
it f because I got sakar uh in that uh
whole thing so I'm not gonna let you do
that and you know see where what we're
willing to go down to something that we
can realistically see it get but if it's
out of that realm we're not doing it
we're not doing it yeah all right so
let's go
you know what let's go Loki
oh Loki that's an a
I think that's an s
well you can argue without Loki we're
not having these movies right now he
literally started the Multiverse
um you know what I'll get I'll I'll give
you
hmm
the only reason
why I'm gonna give you the S ranking in
it is because of frog Thor
so what we're gonna do after this is
once we write them we're going to sort
them from uh least to best so like uh
Spider-Man's definitely better than Loki
uh you know would see if Moon Knight's
better than what if you know what I'm
saying yeah uh all right so let's do the
next one four d
that's not a hell I want to fight
um because I know I have to have my veto
for later
um I do know the cringe within Thor I do
understand
why you know it has the cringe and and
everybody
oh all right I'll go D with you uh
two dollars from Spartan goes try to do
how a house of cards humor without
Talent have you ever seen that show
yeah House of Cards is a fantastic
Netflix show yeah it's a shame that uh
you know Spacey's left it you know he
definitely species didn't leave anything
yeah I mean he definitely didn't like he
needed repercussions but man he was good
in that show yeah but yeah I feel like
you got a sacrifice see like look well
there are certain things where it's like
okay should that dude a guard off no he
definitely needed to get off of that
like get off the show Spacey all right
so this one is looks like Marvel uh
woman whatever that show is called
Captain Marvel you get a pick it I
didn't watch it
oh you didn't watch Captain Marvel I'm
gonna give Kamala Khan uh a b
um she taught me uh a lot of Indian
culture uh stuff that I didn't know and
I loved the use and colorfulness of the
world I love the how they brought the
character to life I don't like the fact
that they didn't explain the bands and
they will do that in the in the Marvel's
movie
[Music]
um
uh I think I think those are quasars
bands oh Spartan says trash
yes you know I'm I'm seeing a trend with
you Spartan
all right all right all right all right
um eternals
oh eternals I'm I'm very high on turtles
because I like Jack Curry b b or a yeah
yeah because I don't I don't know why
people don't like the movie so much like
like I actually really enjoyed it I felt
like they did more in that movie to show
a character like flash than they've ever
done on anything on DC like you felt
like you felt like she was actually
using her speed to her advantage and not
just like being a smart ass with her
speed you know what I'm saying
especially at the end where she she runs
at it but she takes his head and rips it
on the sidewalk it just drags it down
the the mountain what I what people
don't really know is that character is a
male agenda swap that character I I
liked her though I liked her but they I
loved the fact of why they gender
swapped the character so I I rolled with
it because he's one of my favorite uh
eternals so it was cool almost cool all
right so this this next one I can I
think it's Wanda uh I think it's a
black panther yeah it's uh for a wanted
forever where's that going
oh wakanda forever yeah
a b
I kind of want to get hey man I I really
felt like
it did everything it was supposed to
like I really like the antagonist but
I'll go with B with you I'll go with B
the only reason why I'm going to give it
a b
is because
um
I wanted I wanted certain things to
happen in the film and then certain
things that did happen in the film
wasn't necessary
for narratives stake or anything so I
felt that it was an agenda again in this
film and I'm seeing agendas start to
Peak they little ugly heads through the
whole phase four you know to be honest
with you
okay here's a rough one man
Doctor Strange
oh Doctor Strange gotta give it a c man
I want I want to give it a C2 like I was
talking to Tyler apparently Tyler's very
fond of this movie I think he was
smoking something before he watched it
he hadn't been doing some kind of
illegal drugs to even think this movie I
low-key want to say this is a d that's
how bad I am like this but I do feel
like it was better than uh Black Widow
and Thor I want to see the real
uh
Doctor Strange in a Multiverse because
remember Sam Raimi came on and actually
uh picked up the script after the fact
right that the original director was
working on it so you can see a lot of
Sam raimi's influence in the film and
watching the film it felt very uh 1990
spider-man-ish so I was waiting for Toby
McGuire to pop out at any any second
there so
I really want to see the original script
the original uh thought process because
it was supposed to be
a horror film you had horror takes in it
but you didn't have a horror film so Sam
Raimi even though he has a horror
background I think he kind of missed the
mark on certain things I didn't like the
fact of what happened with the most
omnipotent Doctor Strange gets beat like
that and you know I'm sorry we built him
up from what if for him to get taken out
by some musical notes very quickly I'm
sorry I just I can't drink that Kool-Aid
okay what about
Winter Soldier and Captain America
got them all when we went to I mean
Captain America and I went to Soldier
yeah I got to give a b to that I thought
it was a very good show I actually
thought it was one of the better shows
like definitely one of the better shows
I don't like Anthony Mackey okay what
what about uh Xiao Chi or shallow chi
chi yeah give it a
yeah I thought I think this is almost s
almost s it was close to an s
it just misses the Mark
um I think by bad casting I think they
could have cast uh the lead character
better I think he was good though I
thought he was good I'm uh I mean I feel
you I feel you it's it again this is the
stupid comic book purest dude uh that's
that's that's coming out of me
it's a character that's supposed to
emulate or look like Bruce Lee
he didn't feel you I feel you right he
didn't he did emulate him he didn't look
like him he wasn't the embodiment of
them so at that period of time we had
black exploitation films we had a lot of
karate movies you got to look at the
period of time when Chung Chi comes out
and chongqi comes out because Bruce Lee
is very popular at this time so you
needed a Bruce Lee character and this
was the Bruce Lee character he just
didn't fit that that mold for me so I
think they miscast the lead for me I
feel like I will give it an a all right
so this is where we're gonna go back I
haven't used my veto and you haven't
either oh we got a Super Chat five
dollar Super Chat from Corey Tidwell
Wanda forever should have been an A on
the strength of Angelo uh blast
performance I'm pretty sure yeah okay
hold on I got it uh Corey till well a
five dollar Super Chat uh wakanda fabric
should be a a on the string for Angela
bassett's performance
brother you ain't telling a lie
Angela Bassett
uh gave the best performance
that you can give but tell me as a
strategist and sure he's a strategist
why the hell would you take your whole
Army to the middle of the ocean to fight
uh the the well they're not Atlantis to
fight them literally on their home turf
literally on their homework and you know
what's funny when you finish when you
finish They're All Dead almost yes
there's like five on that ship
makes no sense
all right so this is where we go through
now I have we either one of us hasn't
used our uh veto I have feeling we'll
use it here we're going to write these
from every tier uh so I don't think
we're gonna argue in the first couple of
these we're gonna I gotta read the Super
Chat
there's another Super Chat he said yo
this dude said Wade Johnson said King's
triple Knight he said King the end
credits insulate that evil doctor
strange about I know that's true he he
jumped inside his head I feel you uh
king
um okay so windsweep King David always
thought it would be cool to have a video
game sports music that you know all
those things brother I love you and I
will continue to watch a great work
thank you so much brother I appreciate
that all right so
we're going to go through here what was
better black widow or Thor
I think what what was
yeah I think Black Widow is definitely
the worst uh movie yeah I gotta go with
Thor's a better movie yeah okay so um
Doctor Strange or She-Hulk
Doctor Strange
yeah all right this is where I have a
Philly I don't I think I might use my
veto and hey I ain't cool I'm gonna be
real with you okay I don't know yet I
don't know yet all right so what do you
think here is the worst movie in the B
tier you got yeah you got Hawkeye
um uh the the wool the the werewolf
movie uh looks like one division mm-hmm
uh Miss Marvel
eternals mm-hmm
and Captain America and Winter Soldier I
gotta say uh Hawkeye for me oh you think
Hawkeye is the worst yeah yeah I can
give you that I actually think the one
before that is Miss Marvel
hmm
you're going to use your Vita yes you're
going to use your veto on Miss Marvel I
don't
know I know man because you still go
ahead I gotta hold it no you said it no
no no no I'm holding my veto okay
um
I think the one worse than that young
will get the ones I ain't seen this
werewolf movie the show no I love that
movie okay then Vito no because I know
what you're about to do and I'm not
gonna let that happen all right um
I'ma say
I'm gonna say one division
okay I'm done with that
and then I would say probably
Captain America and Winter Soldier okay
and
I want to say
wakanda forever
okay and eternals is the better one than
that one so you're trying to say that
internals is better than wakanda forever
yeah all these are eternals no I
wouldn't say that the turtles is better
than what kind of feather I'm going to
tell you that uh wakanda Fab is better
than eternals no are you sure you want
you want to put your veto power behind
that stage see that's what you want me
to do because I know what you want to
win with you going after the A-list
because you know what I'm gonna be using
my veto power
because you want Sean G to come out on
top
yeah no man I'm good you can let that be
what it is
all right so
what's the worst here I'm gonna say Moon
Knight
okay okay
so
that means it goes between so what if
last
and Shawty is the best
wait wait wait I just vetoed so that
means no UV told to make it not last
[Applause]
it wouldn't have mattered because I
would have just vetoed first place like
ah this guy is crazy yo what if it's
better than Sean cheek
[Laughter]
you manipulated the rules
and obviously um
you know and Spider-Man obviously is
better than local I couldn't even troll
to make that number one like to make
this guy here
so yeah I think this is a song I think
this is a song list you know there is
there's a couple
nah not my list our list is perfect
perfect
yeah so we're gonna put out a poll this
week
um to to come up with
um
what the topic what what movie we should
watch
because you know what people coming up
on yeah sorry go ahead and finish no
we're we're coming up on
um
the last week of ILP so attic and I are
still debating on if we're going to do
the show on Tuesday which we probably
might do what this coming up Tuesday
yeah are we well we have to because um
uh Avatar
oh yeah all right after that we'll
probably take the break till next year
all right so then we're doing Avatar
movies already uh solidified and uh
we'll talk about some other news if news
happens yeah but most likely it it I
don't I don't know the movie industry
that well like the gaming industry but
if it's like any other industry thing
much happening now yeah
people are hurt right now this the
turtles is not better than Wanda but you
know what's funny king tried so hard to
finesse me he let me have my way with
that beat
yo I literally knew what you were doing
and I couldn't stop it you don't like
watching a game of tic-tac-toe you know
what's funny too my whole I Was Gonna
Save The veto
for the eternals but you didn't make me
use it nah so I was like okay he's not
making me use it that's that's what's up
I wasn't because uh a lot of those
movies are are really beat here a lot of
them uh you know the movies and shows
that we did get that are asked here are
very few and far between so you got to
take your hats off to Sony and uh Robert
Henderson uh for um
for you know doing what they did to get
these uh movies and these shows to where
they had the ATS stuff is really good
stuff for you to watch anyway so watch
Moon night watch what if and watch Young
Chi not saying that the BTS trash the B
tear is really really good stuff it's
just really glaring flaws within uh
these shows and these movies that uh
allow you to realize it's b c those are
seriously flawed good shows that are
willing you're willing to struggle
through them d
by all costs if you do it do it at your
own risk yeah so pretty much how I would
say is you can watch like if you were
going to watch these movies watch them
in the tears that we put them just it's
you up to you which one you want to
watch first in the tears yeah now
obviously if you really want to keep up
to date on the Marvel stuff you're gonna
have to watch CND like unfortunately
because I don't really fan of some of uh
the choices I made a d I actually feel
like
black widow's still a c type move type
but you know because I didn't the task
see the thing is I don't have no
connections to task uh whatever his name
is so it didn't bother me but let me go
back to uh
to to this one
uh so we got two dollar Super Chat from
Artemis forget uh guards of the Galaxy
special s tier uh that Christmas I
didn't watch that it wasn't on there
either the the uh the Christmas
Guardians of the Galaxy yeah
the Guardians of the Galaxy uh the
Christmas special is really dope I
watched it yesterday and we we might do
more of these in the future I don't know
because I I really enjoyed that that was
fun I had a good time man I had a good
time you had a good time at it yeah that
was fun especially how uh I finessed the
whole B and 80. yeah you definitely uh
use the gauntlet like Thanos yeah
so now I'm just gonna pass out because
the The Gauntlet killed me
but you know that's pretty much the show
you guys uh you know I think I will cut
that Marvel
video off of the off of the video like
I'm gonna download it cut the mo the
Marvel face thing I'm gonna upload that
as a separate video okay because I feel
like that actually people might enjoy
that but appreciate it for coming
through this is Lord Addison King David
we will see you on iron Lords podcast
this Sunday at 1pm we actually have a
nice guest for you guys and then we're
gonna do a community uh day we actually
my birthday is December 17th so this
Saturday uh so we'll be streaming
something I don't know what it is most
likely Halo I know I said I wouldn't
mess with that but that that Community
updates crazy uh so definitely check
into that is anything you want to say
King no man listen I love everybody for
coming out we had a 77 almost 80 people
strong watching and currently so I do
appreciate it I was actually going to
pick the time out to come out and hang
out with us that was probably the most
support we got in the show so far yeah
well we've got to be consistent with
them you know and and I was late I do
apologize but I was late for absolute
reason
um do I have it on me nope I took it off
I don't even think I could talk about it
to be honest with you you can't not till
next month yeah so so I appreciate
everyone coming through yeah we're gonna
go ahead and uh play that uh intro again
see you guys later
[Music]
foreign
[Music]